[Música]
a medida que europa experimente un
incremento de casos de kobe 19 en esta
segunda ola las hospitalizaciones
aumentan rápidamente generando
preocupaciones en las unidades de
cuidados intensivos a medida que se
acerca el invierno en francia el
presidente de manuel macrón anunciará
hoy más restricciones en las ciudades
donald trump y joe biden se concentran
en los estados claves de pensilvania y
florida donde buscan conquistar el voto
a tres semanas de las elecciones
presidenciales
trump crítico e incluso se burló de su
oponente mientras tanto el demócrata lo
acusó en florida de haber tratado a los
adultos mayores como prescindibles
durante esta pandemia
faltan cuatro días para las elecciones
generales en bolivia y hoy los partidos
cierran sus campañas en distintos puntos
del país entre ellos luís arce en el
alto mientras que carlos meza y luís
fernando camacho lo harán en santa cruz
analizamos desde el país andino lo que
está en juego en estas votaciones
hola como estan buenos dias en américa
latina' ya todos ustedes que nos siguen
por la señal de france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria sean bienvenidos comenzamos
esta emisión en francia- y es que la
situación en el país galo sigue
empeorando el gobierno podría
implementar nuevas restricciones severas
para frenar la propagación de el
coronavirus el presidente de manuel
macrón anunciaría nuevas medidas aunque
un nuevo confinamiento nacional es poco
probable por su potencial impacto
económico una opción serían los toques
de queda nocturnos en las áreas más
afectadas veamos más detalles en el
siguiente informe
los hospitales están siendo empujados
otra vez a un punto de quiebre más de
5.600 pacientes nuevos de kobe 19 fueron
internados la semana pasada unos 1000
están en cuidados intensivos y las camas
de esas unidades se están saturando
rápidamente tendremos el 90% de las
camas reservadas para pacientes graves
de kobe 19 llenas la próxima semana si
no hubiera problemas económicos pienso
que la decisión de volver al
confinamiento se habría tomado hacia
algún tiempo hasta el martes francia
tenía más de 756 mil casos confirmados
con alrededor de 13.000 nuevos contagios
en 24 horas aunque es la mitad del
récord alcanzado el sábado no se espera
que el rebrote acabe pronto desde que
las pruebas masivas comenzaron el 12 por
ciento de los resultados han sido
positivos es decir más de una persona de
cada 10 en parís el promedio es del 17%
las expectativas son altas por los
anuncios del presidente de manuel macrón
quien implementaría restricciones más
duras aunque un confinamiento nacional
está fuera de la mesa por ahora su
primer ministro advirtió que nada
debería ser descartado
y una movilización en una movilización
general es absolutamente necesaria
hemos sufrir las consecuencias muy
rápido de la primera ola caos
pittman de laponia outback montpellier y
toulouse se han unido a la lista de
ciudades francesas bajo alerta máxima en
esas áreas se se ha ordenado el cierre
de bares pero es difícil controlar las
fiestas en casas particulares toques de
queda nocturnos son vistos como el
próximo paso probable estos han sido
efectivos en territorios de ultramar
como la guyana francesa que mantiene la
medida desde marzo
en eeuu si en la batalla electoral a
medida que se acerca a la cita en las
urnas el martes el presidente de donald
trump estuvo en pensilvania donde
criticó e incluso se burló de su
oponente mientras tanto el demócrata joe
biden lo acusó en florida de haber
tratado a los adultos mayores como
prescindibles durante la pandemia del
cob y 19 y justamente las elecciones
estadounidenses se deciden la mayoría de
las veces gracias a estos estados que no
tienen un patrón definido de voto hacia
ninguno de los dos partidos
aurora abajo con los detalles
a sólo tres semanas de las elecciones el
presidente trump está a la defensiva en
los estados claves para la campaña
tratando de revivir su coalición de 2016
en pensilvania donde necesita aumentar
el apoyo de los votantes
el presidente desprecio a su rival
demócrata joe biden como peón de
comunistas que cerró las fábricas
uno de los asuntos más importantes para
pensilvania es la supervivencia de su
industria de fracking joe biden ha
prometido repetidamente abolir el
fracking y es un mentiroso vale es un
mentiroso bailén les encerrada quieren
cerrarlos al igual que su gobernador les
tiene encerrados ahora mismo será mejor
que abra su estado
el coronavirus fue apenas mencionado
igualmente o incluso más importante en
los comicios que pensilvania florida es
un estado considerado campo de batalla y
triunfo grande en 2016 pero esta vez las
encuestas favorecen a bailén en ese
estado el candidato demócrata mantuvo un
evento mucho más reducido en
concordancia con la campaña de bajo
perfil que mantiene esta es la elección
más importante de nuestras vidas usted
puede hacer toda la diferencia aquí en
florida puede determinar el resultado en
esta elección
ganamos florida y se acabó
[Música]
el candidato demócrata también cortejo a
los adultos mayores diciéndoles que
trump nunca ha estado enfocado en ellos
mientras que tram se burló de él en su
cuenta de twitter al publicar un
fotomontaje donde aparece baiden en una
silla de ruedas dentro de un lugar de
retiro una victoria de bailén sobre 30
en florida pondría en serio peligro las
posibilidades de reelección del
presidente las últimas encuestas
muestran que el demócrata va a la cabeza
en el listado
seguimos en eeuu la candidata a la corte
suprema- emmy con y barrett regresa al
capitolio este miércoles para un tercer
día de audiencias en medio de una
campaña electoral en la que el puesto
del tribunal supremo se ha convertido en
uno de los temas centrales durante la
audiencia del martes barrett se
pronunció entre otros temas sobre el
obamacare el aborto el racismo y el
matrimonio homosexual aunque no
respondió a varias de las preguntas que
le formularon los legisladores
demócratas e insistió en que no traerá
una agenda personal a la corte diana
castañeda nuestra corresponsal en
washington nos informa más sobre lo
ocurrido ayer y sobre la sesión de este
miércoles
era la última de barrett ante el comité
judicial del senado
hola buenos días para hoy se espera una
jornada extensa en esta nueva audiencia
del interior del senado como lo hemos
visto en los dos días anteriores con
fuertes cuestionamientos sobre todo por
parte de senadores demócratas hacia
barrett y es que el día de ayer
respondió preguntas sobre uno de los
temas más polémicos al interior de los
eeuu uno de ellos la justicia racial
asegurando que había parcialidad racial
al momento de ejercer el sistema
criminal de justicia en el país también
pidió disculpas por haber utilizado el
término de preferencia sexual hacer
referencia a temas relacionados con la
comunidad lgbt igualmente aseguró que en
caso de que existiera una crisis
electoral si llegara al tribunal supremo
de justicia
trataría de analizar el caso en
particular evitó dar una respuesta
concreta y es que ésta fue una de las
principales críticas de los senadores
demócratas quienes sostienen que esta es
la razón principal por la cual el
presidente de donald trump trató de
acelerar su iluminación y ahora
su posible confirmación ya que en caso
de que se llegue a dar un reconteo de
votos después de las elecciones
presidenciales y no se llegue a un
resultado claro de quién sería el
mandatario entonces sería la corte
suprema a la que tendría que decidir
quién es el presidente de la nación
tercer capítulo de nuestra serie sobre
el incendio en el campo de demandantes
de asilo de moria que en grecia reavivó
las tensiones que había entre los
habitantes de lesbos a favor y en contra
de la acogida de emigrantes las
autoridades griegas dicen sentirse
presionadas por la población y han
anunciado el cierre de otros dos campos
que funcionan en la isla y que hasta
ahora eran citados como un ejemplo de
acogida digna nuestra enviada especial
erika olabarría nos trae la historia
es un lugar de paz para los migrantes
más vulnerables el campo de pippa fue
creado en el 2012 por la ong riesgo
solidario de la estructura cuenta con
100 vacantes para demandantes de asilo
considerados vulnerables debido a la
presión de la población local sin
embargo el gobierno griego ha prometido
cerrar este establecimiento lo más
pronto posible
tenemos 21 menores no acompañados
tenemos una madre soltera que acaba de
llegar ayer del nuevo campo con un bebé
recién nacido y un niño pequeño tenemos
personas con discapacidad en condiciones
de salud muy graves a dónde irán luego
luego
el ministerio de migración pretende
también cerrar antes de fin de año el
antiguo campo de karate administrado por
la municipalidad y donde viven 800
personas en su mayoría familias
vulnerables el gobierno griego quiere
juntar a todos los migrantes en un solo
campo para controlarlos mejor y de paso
dar tranquilidad a una población que
está cansada después de cinco años de
crisis migratoria el pueblo de pan y
aguda está justo frente al campo donde
están agrupando a los migrantes nosotros
nos da menos mucho como comer nos nos
han dejado de lado giren esto los
vecinos que conducen hasta mitilene
tienen que atravesar este desorden
te obligan a ver toda esta sociedad está
creo que la unión europea nos ayuda
económicamente pero su objetivo es que
los mantengamos aquí arde quien el
gobernador de las islas del norte del
mar egeo ha decidido presionar a atenas
para sacar a los migrantes de la
exposición de edificio
al comienzo eran refugiados que huían de
la guerra en siria y fueron bien
recibidos pero la población ha cambiado
son sobre todo migrantes economía
y eso no se detiene jamás la gente aquí
no puede más hace 5 años les fue
conocida como la isla de la solidaridad
pero el ambiente ha cambiado el gobierno
griego se ha comprometido a sacar de la
isla antes de la semana santa a los
12.000 habitantes que tenía moría en el
momento del incendio este miércoles es
el cierre de campaña en bolivia previo a
las votaciones generales de este domingo
los principales actos masivos se
concentraron en la recta final pues al
inicio de la carrera electoral había más
restricciones por la pandemia el
movimiento al socialismo del ex
presidente evo morales organiza su
último encuentro en la ciudad del alto
mientras comunidad ciudadana de carlos
meza y creemos de luís fernando camacho
lo harán en santa cruz la misión
electoral de la organización de los
estados americanos en bolivia pidió a
los candidatos y a la población civil
aceptar los resultados de las elecciones
generales de manera pacífica
es por ello que nos comunicamos con
jorge richard ramírez él es politólogo
boliviano muy buenos días en la paz
señor ritchter que es lo que está en
juego en estas elecciones a la
presidencia en bolivia
buen día a alan un gusto por supuesto en
bolivia hoy en día se están debatiendo
dos formas de gobierno de gobernabilidad
una en un bajo una mirada unipolar
anclada a lo que significa el partido
del ex presidente evo morales en una
perspectiva de que ellos tienen la
posibilidad de otorgarle al país
estabilidad social y gobernabilidad con
su capa con la capacidad de su sola
estructura política y una gobernabilidad
que debe ser negociada compartida en
función de pactos políticos que es la
que podría ofrecer el señor carlos meza
bajo la lógica solamente de poder llevar
adelante e implementar un gobierno con
un pacto político democrático con el
señor luís fernando camacho del
departamento de santa cruz que ocupa el
tercer lugar son dos formas de gobierno
y dos miradas de democracia distintas
también
en argentina viven más de 120 mil
bolivianos que podrán votar el domingo
porque son importantes estos votos para
evo morales- que vive en ese país
porque nosotros en bolivia tenemos la
siguiente norma que está señalada en la
constitución política del estado cuando
la brecha del primero y del segundo
cuando o mejor se mejor dicho cuando el
candidato que gana la elección no llega
al 50% tiene que tener en su caso una
brecha de 10 puntos porcentuales que le
permiten ganar la primera en primera
vuelta
lo que hoy está sucediendo es que
estamos entre alrededor de un punto y un
punto 3 por ciento de diferencia para
evitar la segunda vuelta o asistir a la
misma y en ese sentido en la comunidad
boliviana que está en la argentina suma
aproximadamente el 4 por ciento del
padrón boliviano y en esa perspectiva la
elección se podría definir en primera
vuelta en función de lo que haga la
comunidad boliviana en la argentina cuál
es la tendencia entonces en estas formas
de gobierno que usted plantea
hoy la tendencia está sobre si vamos a
dirimir el proceso electoral en una
primera vuelta donde el señor arce
podríamos señalar tiene su única
posibilidad de acceder a la presidencia
una segunda vuelta favorece ya al
conjunto de fuerzas del centro hacia la
derecha que pueden aglutinar su voto
como señalan las encuestas en función de
la candidatura del señor carlos meza y
ahí está la disputa más intensa del
proceso electoral como le decía con
alrededor de un punto 1.3 por ciento de
diferencia para ver si ésta se cierra en
primera vuelta o en segunda vuelta estas
son hoy en día las tendencias y caminan
pidiendo y solicitándole los sectores de
centroderecha para intentar llegar a
esta segunda vuelta solicitándole le
decía al señor luís fernando camacho el
tercero en las encuestas que pueda hacer
dejación o abandono de su candidatura
para transferir esa intención de voto al
señor carlos meza y que con ello puedan
asegurar la realización de la segunda
vuelta
muy bien pues muchas gracias jorge
ritchter ramírez por esta comunicación y
por su análisis el es politólogo
boliviano en la paz y muchas gracias a
ustedes por su compañía les recordamos
la información no se detiene con
actualizaciones constantes aquí en
nuestra señal televisiva y también
información al momento en nuestro sitio
web france24 puntocom que disfrute de su
día y sigas cuidando mucho del
coronavirus
[Música]